[Applaus]
[Musik]
japan gegen südkorea und südkorea gegen
japan die abhandeln china und china
gegen japan südkorea versus hier und
china versus südkorea und inmitten
dessen eingequetscht nord korea und
taiwan liebe zuschauer ostasien ist wenn
es das nicht schon immer war zu einer
brutstätte der konfrontationen und
diplomatischen krise zwischen den drei
mächtigsten nachbarregionen worden china
japan und südkorea konflikte liefe das
westliche auge manchmal lächerlich
erscheinen mögen aber in ostasien viel
mehr sind als einfacher territoriale
reibereien bei denen es darum geht wen
welche winzige insel gehört ja es geht
tatsächlich um inseln die in einigen
fällen wie wir das später sehen werden
nicht viel mehr als felsbrocken sind das
problem wenn wir es so nennen können ist
dass es in diesem teil der welt neben
der territorialen frage auch eine
komponente der ehre des nationalismus
und vor allem ein gefühl des
bedürfnisses nach selbstverteidigung
gibt das viel mit dem dunklen
ereignissen des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
zu tun hat ereignisse wie weniger als 80
jahre zurücklägen im gegensatz zu europa
aber nie richtig aufgearbeitet worden
sind
[Musik]
in der ersten hälfte des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts führte japan nämlich einen
aggressiven vernichtungskrieg zur
ausdehnung seines reiches in ost und
südostasien der im grunde schon 1904 den
russisch-japanischen krieg begann und
mit der kapitulation des japanischen
reiches 1945 endete diese imperiale
expansion osten zig millionen menschen
das leben darunter auch millionen von
zivilisten die bei zahlreichen massa
kann wahllosen angriffe exekutionen
menschen versuchen und einer dies hat
anderer gräueltaten und kriegsverbrechen
ihr leben verloren dieser japanische
expansions- feldzug beinhaltet natürlich
die besetzung zahlreicher länder und
obwohl die schilder rechnung des
vertrags von san francisco 1951 die
rückgabe aller besetzten gebiete und
ehemaligen kolonien an die jeweiligen
völker nach dem fall des japanischen
kaiserreich regelte haben gewisse
rechtliche schlupflöcher und
unklarheiten dazu geführt dass sie aber
einige davon immer noch als sein
eigentum beansprucht das ist der grund
warum einige der opfer des japanischen
imperiums jedes mal die krallen
ausfahren wenn japan sagt dass dieses
oder jenes gebieten gehört natürlich ist
das aber nicht der einzige grund du
musst den wachsenden einfluss chinas und
den erbitterten kampf um jeden
quadratmeter jener exklusiven
wirtschaftszone berücksichtigen auch
dieser hat viele dieser politischen
auseinandersetzungen erheblich angereist
[Musik]
die bekanntesten sind die samp cargo
inseln und die sich japan sowohl
mitglieder als auch mit taiwan streitet
die doktor inseln und die ist nicht mehr
zu korea soft und mit deutlich weniger
medienrummel die südlichen teile der
russischen kurilen inseln sowie das
südliche apollo kino toro china dieser
ort okimoto china ist ein insel atolle
von dem du wahrscheinlich noch nie was
gehört hast aber er hat eine unglaublich
kuriose geschichte hinter sich welche
die zukunft der region erheblich
beeinflussen könnte freundin in diesem
video werden wir euch genau sagen was
hinter all diesen territorialkonflikte
steckt konflikte die in einigen fällen
die gewässer die japan von china
südkorea und russland rennen zu einem
hotspot gemacht haben der schärfer ist
als ein hotspot pass gut auf denn es
gibt in dieser geschichte so viel mehr
erstaunliche dinge zu erfahren als wir
uns auf den ersten blick vorstellen
können also lasst uns gleich loslegen
[Musik]
silka cool er fabrizierte konflikt
[Applaus]
hast du schon mal von den instinkt akku
inseln gehört oder bist du eher mit
ihren chinesischen namen diabolo
vertraut im westen haben wahrscheinlich
die meisten von beidem noch nie was
gehört in ostasien sind die dinge jedoch
sehr sehr anders die senkaku inseln sind
eine gruppe von fünf inseln und drei
völlig ungewohnten felsen die zwischen
japan taiwan und dem chinesischen
festland liegen die den drei ländern am
nächsten gelegene insel befindet sich
einer strategischen position nämlich 170
kilometer von taiwan entfernt 170
kilometer von der japanischen insel
ishigaki und 330 kilometer von der küste
des chinesischen festlands wie so viele
andere insel in der gegend erkannte
japan sie 1895 als eigenes territorium
an kurz vor beginn seiner militärischen
expansion als japan strategie darin
bestand ungewohnt ist der regelung auf
allen relativ nahen insel zurück zu
erobern diese gruppe hatte mehr als 200
einwohner hauptsächlich fischer die von
den reichen fischgründen in der umgebung
leben das kuriose an dieser geschichte
ist nichts so sehr wie die japaner ihres
unsere realität über dieses gebiet
beanspruchten sondern was sie danach
taten das kaiserreich japan
privatisierte die synchro insel 1932
nämlich als sie sich an die familie
kober verkaufte die dort ein zentrum für
lebensmittelproduktion errichten wollte
in die harmlos und stürze ich brachte
ihr projekt jedoch zusammen und nach der
japanische niederlage 1945 kamen die
insel unter verwaltung der vereinigten
staaten wie auch ganz japan bis 1952
diese inseln blieben jedoch noch zwei
weitere jahrzehnte bis
1972 unter amerikanischer kontrolle in
jedem jahr wurden die zenk akkus nicht
nur an die japaner zurückgegeben sondern
vier der inseln wurden auch von einer
anderen familie der kurihara familie
gekauft und freunde das ist genau jener
zeitpunkt an denen dieses ganze chaos
begann
[Musik]
mit der rückgabe der inseln durch die
vereinigten staaten in japan begann in
china und taiwan gleichzeitig sie als
ihre eigene zu beanspruchen basierend
auf ihrer nähe und einem historischen
streit über die maritime grenzziehung
eigentlich würden die inseln gemäß
dieser argumentation zur taiba angehören
aber das kommunistische china taiwan
nicht als land anerkennt beanspruchen
sich sich natürlich dass ihr eigenes
eigentum und da ist nicht nur ungewohnt
inseln ohne wertvolle ressourcen
handelte schließen die diplomatischen
und territorialen und legte im laufe der
jahre ein ohne größere probleme zu
verursachen das heißt bis 2012 als sich
plötzlich wieder etwas zu regnen begann
als
das
[Musik]
was denkst du was 2012 passiert sein
könnte um das sim karten probleme neu zu
entfachen nun japan hat damals
beschlossen die insel zu verstaatlichen
genau ist kaufte die inseln von der
kurihara familie zurück machte den
schutz des archivs zu einer nationalen
priorität und verstärkte sogar die
militäreinheiten die um die insel herum
stationiert sind die ließ waren dass der
china dazu zum ersten mal seit 1958 ein
überwachungsflugzeug über den luftraum
der insel zu schicken und nicht du das
chinesische übergriffe und japanische
antworten darauf sind seither zu einer
konstante in der region geworden
tatsächlich erreichten sie jüngst einen
höhepunkt dar schiffe der chinesischen
küstenwache regelmäßig um diese insel
patroullieren was genau hat ida dazu
veranlasst druck und wachsamkeit
gegenüber des ergo gruppe zu erhöhen nun
überraschenderweise läuft es auf
folgendes hin aus
abstimmungen japan zur änderung des
status der umstrittenen inseln droht die
spannungen in china zu erhöhen der
stadtrat von der japanischen präfektur
okinawa stimmte dem gesetz zu das den
attraktiven status der unbewohnten
inselgruppe ändert die in japan als
zirkus und in china als die os bekannt
sind das gesetz ändert den namen der
insel für administrative zwecke von
tomasz cero in tornow chirurg akku über
eine namensänderung obwohl es schwer zu
glauben ist reicht eine einfache
namensänderung durch einen stadtrat aus
um ein diplomatisches scharmützel
internationalen ausmaßes zu entfesselt
die die audio essen und die zugehörigen
inseln sind chinas uhr eigenes
territorium china ist entschlossen seine
territoriale souveränität zu schützen
diese sogenannte administrative
umwidmung ist eine ernsthafte
provokation gegenüber chinas
territoriale souveränität yao jian ein
sprecher des chinesischen
außenministeriums tja sagt mir jetzt
nicht dass das ganze nicht wie ein
schlechter witz klingt aber die realität
ist auch seltsam denn so laufen die
dinge nun mal in ostasien fakt ist das
ist rechtlich gesehen keinen zweifel
daran gibt dass die senkaku-inseln
derzeit japanisches territorium sind und
die ansprüche taiwans und chinas
scheinen keinen großen einfluss darauf
zu haben alles also nur harmloses
säbelrasseln ohne reale auswirkungen nun
mit titel ping an der spitze chinas weiß
man nie wichtig ist der kontext im
komplexen gefüge der internationalen
diplomatie denn wer bereits zu beginn
des videos erwähnt haben ist dies bei
weitem nicht der einzige territoriale
konflikte in den japan verwickelt ist
der andere konflikt mit südkorea
betrifft die doktor inseln aber moment
mal sind japan und südkorea nicht beide
demokratische verbündete der usa sie
sollten doch zusammenhalten gegen das
totalitäre china nun sagen wir einfach
mal dass sich diese beiden länder so gut
verstehen die katze und hund was genau
ich damit meine aufgepasst
[Musik]
es geht nicht um den inseln sondern um
die ehre
im ost mehr zwischen den koreanischen
halbinsel und japan liegt doch nur zwei
inselchen und einer handvoll felsen die
dennoch zu einem der charakteristischen
symbole des südkoreanischen patriotismus
geworden sind aber wie um alles in der
welt konnten zwei felsbrocken mitten im
meer wo praktisch nichts los ist zu
einem modernen symbol ist eine die
japanischen widerstands werden nun um
das ganze zu verstehen denke ich müssen
wir jetzt doch mal einen kurzen blick in
die geschichte werfen
die doktor inseln sind international als
auch leo chur felsen oder in japan als
tag in china bekannt sie werden in alten
schriften erwähnt die behaupten dass die
inseln bereits im jahr 512 zur zeit des
koreanischen siller königreichs zu korea
dr im neuesten titel währenddessen rose
spanischen krieges besetzte sich das
kaiserreich japan und kurz darauf im
jahr 1910 wurden sie wie der rest der
koreanischen halbinsel als eigenes
territorium des japanischen reiches
annektiert deshalb symbolisiert oktober
die koreaner das erste territorium dass
der japanischen besetzung von 1910 zum
opfer fiel und ist für sie teil der in
dieser zeit kolonisierten territorien
tatsache ist dass diese inseln nach dem
fall des japanischen reiches nur 145
wieder in koreanischer hand waren oder
zumindest glaubten die koreaner das
können sie denn für die japaner waren
sie damals nicht mehr als niemandsland
hat sie daher nach eigener auffassung in
einer auch beanspruchen konnten aber
wurde nicht durch die
entkolonialisierung koreas und die
auflösung des japanischen kaiserreich
der status der doktor festgelegt nun
schau dir an was artikel 2a des
vertrages von san francisco besagt japan
erkennt die unabhängigkeit koreas an und
verzichtet auf alle rechte titel und
ansprüche auf korea eigentlich nicht der
insel quelle para sport hamilton und
agilität artikel 28 des vertrages von
san francisco tja wie du sich bemerkt
hast werden die reha kur felsen nicht
ausdrücklich im vertrag erwähnt und das
ist das rechtliche vakuum das japan
nutzt um weiterhin anspruch auf die
inseln zu erheben
aus diesem grund drehen sich die
argumente zur verteidigung der
koreanischen souveränität über diese
inseln im wesentlichen um historisches
geografische und sogar geologische
debatten genau theologische debatten dpa
das ist nämlich der meinung dass die
teil der konnte in den teilen plattform
das südkoreanischen insel new york times
sind die 94 kilometer entfernt liegt
während die nächst gelegenen japanischen
inseln die ok inseln 157 kilometer von
doktor entfernt sind tatsächlich ist der
diplomatische konflikt und doktor
überraschend weise lebendiger denn je
zum teil wegen denen wie diesen
156 jahre alte karte könnte den insel
streit zwischen japan und südkorea neu
entfachen auf dieser karte von 1861 war
doktor als teil des königreichs korea
eingezeichnet die karte war bis 2017
teil der sammlung eines japaners
ironischerweise war des japaners der sie
1932 erwartet und bis jetzt wohl auf
seinem dachboden versteckt hielt davor
hatte sich in einer bibliothek in kenia
gefunden
[Musik]
ein anderes dokument von japans großen
staatsrat aus dem jahr 1877 besagt dass
dort keine beziehung zu japan hat es
gibt koreanische karten für jeden
geschmack auf denen doch du alles
koreanisches territorium eingezeichnet
ist und wiederum japanische karten die
es als teil der präfektur shimane
beinhalten all das hat zu einer gewissen
mythenbildung darüber geführt der die
inseln kontrollieren sollte und in japan
zumindest in der präfektur shimane
nehmen sie das alles ziemlich ernst das
rechtlich hat die präfektur regierung
den 22 februar zum takeshi mag erklärt
und jedes jahr gibt es virtuelle
handlungen und veranstaltungen welche
die souveränität über druckt untermauern
sollen ein propaganda theater das nicht
nur in japan sondern auch in südkorea
gespielt wird denn obwohl es uns etwas
selbst an vorkommen mag geben beide
regierungen jedes jahr millionen von
dollar aus und für die souveränität von
doktor zu werben haben institutionelle
webseiten ihrer jeweiligen
außenministerien ich versuchen das ganze
zu erklären und schalten sogar anzeigen
auf der straße oder in der u-bahn also
wer kontrolliert diese insel heute nun
im moment ist ist südkorea
[Musik]
er ist unterhält ein rotierendes militär
kontingent von 39 man das permanent auf
diese insel stationiert ist es gibt dort
sogar ein paar inselbewohner die
allerdings schon älter sind die inseln
möglicherweise sehr bald verlassen
müssen um zugang zu medizinischer
behandlung zu erhalten bei den soldaten
die auf der wache schieben hat es sich
in der regel um junge wehrpflichtige die
sich diesen ort aussuchen was sie sich
vorstellen dass sie dort nichts zu tun
haben werden und sie haben recht denn es
gibt da recht nichts zu tun denn auf
diese nützlichen gibt es nur einen
kleinen vier einen wachposten ein
leuchtturm ein briefkasten und ein paar
wanderwege sonst nichts
unterdessen schlägt japan seit jahren
vor diesen streit internationalen
gerichtshof in den haag zur entscheidung
vorzulegen was zu ablehnt weil das für
sie einem eingeständnis gleich käme dass
es zweifel an der souveränität eines
territoriums gibt das ihrer ansicht nach
im rahmen ehemaligen japanischen
kolonisation gewaltsam besetzt wurde und
an diesem punkt fragen sich
wahrscheinlich viele von euch aber was
um alles welt ist ein doktor was das
interesse dieser beiden mächtigen
industrieländer wecken würde was
rechtfertigt den permanenten einsatz von
39 soldaten oder dass die ministerien
beider länder auch nur eine einzige
minute ihre aufmerksamkeit für diese
geschichte verschwenden sollten nun
freunde an dieser stelle wird es
interessant
[Musik]
denn einige berichte sprechen von einem
risiko gasvorkommen in der region von
oder irgendwo und doktor das den
gesamten gasbedarf südkoreas einen
zeitraum von 30 bis 100 jahren decken
könnte und vergesst nicht dass südkorea
ein großer verbraucher von erdgas ist
übrigens sei es kleine herr antwortet
wusstest du das doch nur einmal
bombardiert wurde und nein der gegner
war nicht japan sondern die usa im jahr
1948 führte die usa mir einige raketen
übungen durch die sehr sehr schlecht
endeten es stellte sich heraus dass
gerade zurzeit übungen etwa 80
südkoreanisches fischerboot aus seetang
sammelten das ergebnis 16 tote koreaner
und ein absolut ruhiger ruf der us armee
in korea aber heute können dieses video
nicht beenden ohne euch von dem kuriosen
fall von o'connor tory china zu erzählen
wenn der insel die ihm ja nicht einmal
eine esel ist wird ist gut so
was unter wasser
was würdest du denken wenn ich dir sagen
würde dass japan erheblich die
diplomatische anstrengungen unternimmt
um ein paar tage felsen mitten in der
philippinischen sie zurückzuerobern die
kaum 20 zentimeter über den
meeresspiegel ragen und die eine
gesamtfläche von
0,008 quadratkilometer haben was hältst
du davon
[Musik]
die rede ist von ok lotterie china einem
von ihr japan beanspruchten quartalen
rest dass sich kaum sichtbar unter
wasser befindet mit zwei kleinen felsen
die mit beton aufgeschüttet worden um zu
verhindern dass sie bei flut runtergehen
ich meine das grenzt schon an subs wurde
allem anschein nach scheint es ein
verzweifelter versuch zu sein einige
felsen zu konservieren die ohne beton
höchstwahrscheinlich im meer
verschwinden würden und die frage lautet
warum eigentlich was bringt jemanden
dazu mitten im meer einen haufen
betreuung auch ein paar felsen zu
schützen nun es gibt eine erklärung für
alters
japan hier nämlich ist die anerkennung
einer exklusiven wirtschaftszone die
sich 200 seemeilen das heißt etwa 370 km
um diese helfen erstreckt und das ist
genauso viel wie den küsten zvolen jedes
continental landes oder denen von
besiedelten und konsolidierten insel
zugestanden wird ja als absicht ist es
in diesem fall dieses gebiet mit china
ist ausschließliche wirtschaftszone zu
überlappen um ihnen ein stück von diesem
kuchen abzuluchsen natürlich erkennt die
internationale gesetzgebung für fälle
wie diesen in denen es und unbewohnte
inseln geht nur zwölf seemeilen das
heißt 22 kilometer ausschließliche
wirtschaftszone an aber was bedeutet das
alles nun diesen ausschließlichen
wirtschaftszonen haben jeweiligen status
exklusive recht alle ressourcen und
rohstoffe zum beispiel mineralien erdgas
oder fisch die sie für angemessen halten
zu bewirtschaften und abzubauen das
heißt das gebiet so zu nutzen wie sie es
wollen und tatsächlich haben
ausschließliche wirtschaftszonen eine
ganze menge mit allerdings
streitigkeiten zu tun die wir in diesem
video gesehen haben und natürlich gibt
es viele in der die versuchen ihre
ausschließliche wirtschaftszone so groß
wie möglich zu machen aber im fall von
oki notorisch china treiben ist die
japaner einfach zu dort etwas sehr
ähnliches geschieht auch im auto
[Musik]
iro auch doktor hessen genannt ist ein
4,6 meter unter der meeresoberfläche
liegender felsen das zwischen china und
korea liegt und mit der absicht korea
das recht auf eine ausschließliche
wirtschaftszone über diesen felsen zu
queren baute die koreanische regierung
im jahr 2003 eine forschungsplattform
die auf dem versuch in hessen selbst
befestigt ist und auf der die
südkoreanische flagge die ihr eigentum
markiert deutlich sichtbar angebracht
ist das thema otto marx als eines der
surrealistischen video erscheinen da das
essen nicht einmal was denn mehr guckt
aber es ist noch ein weiteres beispiel
dafür wie die drei großen länder aus
asien china südkorea und japan mit allen
mitteln versuchen ihre einflussgebiete
auszudehnen wie es nur geht und
wenn es zufällig bodenschätze das heißt
dass oder dürften sprinter gibt dir ist
jedenfalls zu sein scheint dann umso
mehr aber wie auch immer vorne das sind
die wichtigsten territorialen
streitigkeiten in den gewässern der
meere die japan umgeben und obwohl sie
vielen von uns als lächerliche konflikte
erscheinen mögen ist es eine tatsache
dass sie diplomatische feuer schüren
welche manchmal die spannungen bis zum
äußersten treiben können bis hin zu
militärischen einsätzen drohungen im es
aktionen und dem ständigen risiko dass
die dinge leicht außer kontrolle geraten
könnten und das alles im namen des
nationalstolzes wer ist eigentlich um
exklusive wirtschaftszonen geht ich
hoffe dass du hest wohnungen von diesen
kontroversen hörst ein besseres
verständnis dafür hast was sie zu
bedeuten haben aber erst bist du einer
rein was meinst du gibt es einen weg
diese konflikte irgendwie zu lösen
können sie irgendwann eskalieren gar zu
kriegen führen teile deine einschätzung
wird sich immer mit uns und auch allen
anderen falls du dieses video gut fand
damit ein leichter es mit einem freundin
abonniere unseren vergiss nicht dass
aktivieren damit du keine günstigsten
fall passt und mach's gut bis zum
nächsten mal